hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and it's John Humphrey here over on
Instagram is this app and Instagram they
are they they do movie promotions
sometimes download it follows first well
New Mutants is is one of the comic book
movies I'm most excited for next year
simply because of its genre having more
of the haunted house vibe and they put
together a bunch of like teaser shorts
that they release on their Instagram
page I haven't seen any of them I don't
follow I haven't followed the Instagram
of the New Mutants yet Collider the
website has and they / they put it all
in one page for us to go check it out
and I was like [ __ ] let's check it out
let's see what's going on here oh it's
like a gift oh look religion religious
stuff here
ratch nice and clear aka Wolfsbane and
then what's this one right here there's
no seed you definitely gonna need a
higher power of hashtag New Mutants
[Music]
are you William hey look scary
Guthrie aka cannonball is all meaning
the New Mutants some things can't be
caged hashtag New Mutants Luke Cage okay
Oh dead twitchy bird it's like dead
twitchy bird also kind of like a moving
painting yeah yeah yeah no that's what I
mean it's really setting the tone of
this horror world they have here and
then I was a kid's got from stranger
things they surround you hashtag new
minutes all right it's kind of molten
are stars no it's really it's Raymont it
feels way less like comic book movie
than ever yeah as such as a haunted
house vibe I like the first ones are
always like these like Harry Potter
paintings like moody glimpses into there
what I assume are their little living
quarters their little cells they said
art would save your soul they like Owen
the hands come out
[Music]
it feels like a comic book it doesn't
feel like a superhero movie
yeah the comic book this is smart to do
because a lot of people won't know who
the new units are such as ourselves like
we're not that familiar with them so
this is a great way of teasing who the
characters are and sending up a world
and tone hopefully more people will be
following this Instagram page to help
out with that this is successfully
getting me that much more exciting
brighter the light darker the shadow
black with the biryu what if these
images will actually come into play in
the movie itself yeah me too I mean they
get pretty clever nowadays with
marketing so I would be I would be kind
of psyched if they did Danielle Moonstar
aka Mirage nature never nurtured those
dead animals looks like one the left
looks like a dead one so as I'm on the
right one on the right yeah this one
right here
oh yeah well there's something bleeding
under there I think one of those things
looks like a like a wood carving things
will only get darker hell yeah I wonder
if this is gonna be a movie that's
artistically told I mean that's what
these images are kind of conveying here
to me yeah I mean they're definitely
leading with mood and and you know
images yeah then you know exploitable
element and you know fun stuff the youth
are sick youth are sick and there is no
cure
Wow the horror elements of being a
mutant right here dr. Cecilia Reyes keep
your friends close and your doctors
closer
she's like the architect
[Music]
they're just mutants I mean she's
obviously the antagonist of the film
right it's always the doctor like she's
sinister but not entirely evil who knows
although I and I don't know what that
character is like from the actual
stories and whatnot I'm super saiyan
she's a great actress - Alice bro what
I'm really hoping that this movie does
especially after seeing the way they're
promoting it not just from its first
trailer but from the way how the promo
Instagram they stick with the horror
elements and don't try to transition it
into a superhero movie by the end of it
that's my concern is that they're gonna
try to do some like superhero transition
move yeah or the first 2/3 are like a
really interesting horror horror
superhero crossover than the last third
is just you know really hoping it
remains grounded in this insane asylum
spooky haunted house vibe yeah because
that's what's getting me really excited
for it I know they're doing spawn
rebooting that into a more of a horror
film
Hellboy here's gonna be darker and more
like a horror film or is really in right
now and superhero movies are in 2018 is
gonna be the year they cross yon Rah's
it makes a lot of sense I mean because
horror does really well in times like
these when when we're struggling as a
society but also you know superhero
movies are at the top of the box office
so I don't like it makes kind of a lot
of sense for the two to cross and
especially now that we're more actively
exploring morale and and ideas about
justice in society yes like it makes
sense for these two crossover and this
is the wave of superhero stuff I'm most
excited for across the board
yeah well it's exciting about it is
because for superhero genre to remain
relevant and to remain fresh the thing
about horror is anytime you do something
that is familiar like I feel like a lot
of genres you can get
with familiar and a lot of arenas
because at the end of day if you get
like cool spectacle and you laugh or
whatever but if you do it well enough
you know horror in order to be effective
has to have surprises it has to have
originality mystery a mystery you have
to have unique things in there order for
the horror genre to be effective that's
why I think horror is such a thriving
independent market because that's where
a lot of originality and plus excitement
comes into play films like get out and
split or a lot of things from Plum house
and yeah so with with having a suit with
superhero genre Russ and doubly doubt
that we stay even further away from
superhero fatigue I think incorporating
horror is a great element and also you
know a lot of superhero genre tends to
the families and children this is a more
mature stage comic book movies I think
yeah when I feel like comics lend
themselves a ton to horror anyway I mean
there's so much that we explored it a
little bit and the Fantastic Four but
there's so much potential for body
horror and oh yeah well I'm kind of
hoping this does that yeah yeah me too
and I mean this is in the x-men universe
right and yeah I feel like they
especially do well playing with those
themes and looking within you know as
well as how society treats these people
and and to see how you know maybe some
of the more questionable or dangerous
mutants are treated in this scenario you
know is pretty interesting to me this is
supposed to be the first one right the
first one next year that is a horror
superhero movie and then I think it's
spawned then Hellboy how boys still a
while off oh they wrapped filming on it
oh yeah yeah I met the makeup artist I
actually understood I shot a whole
episode of a TV show that's just as cool
I thought he probably remembers you
loved it sat down to dinner with him for
an hour
talk to him I did work near his show me
photos of Hellboy on his phone okay show
me he's like yeah I like the photo
they're released but there's a lot of
details that you can like let me show
you some photos so like all the hair on
his back and his chassis you can't see
I'm like
that's the is there's a lot of missing
detail you don't get in that photo I
can't tell you anything I know that he
told me but I know some stuff have my
eyes at the end they don't want a friend
[Laughter]
no more of this he'll read nonsense well
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell make sure
to follow us on social media and yep
take care